beach near bali's southern coast is a
popular spot for surfing and dining
this couple are among the few foreign
tourists already in bali
oh my god i
i thought about this place
many so many times so peaceful so
incredible
it's relatively quiet but that may
change soon
i really want to see bali like how it
was before back to normal
late last year indonesia allowed
tourists to travel to bali if they
quarantined in the capital jakarta first
now international direct flights to bali
have resumed for the first time in
almost two years
all visitors must complete five days
hotel quarantine but they won't be
confined to their rooms
in the hotel they can use any facilities
in the hotels that we have
either the restaurant the pool
go to the beach the spa perhaps
other southeast asian countries are also
trying to attract foreign visitors again
but unlike indonesia thailand and the
philippines have no quarantine
requirement
the highly anticipated reopening of bali
comes as covert 19 cases rise again in
indonesia but authorities say they
anticipated the increase and are better
prepared
president joko widodo says indonesia's
hospitals and health workers are ready
overshadowed by the pandemic experts say
it's too soon to say whether the
reopening will be a success
well i think the region's in a state of
flux
uh
we've been waiting almost two years uh
there's been a big period of uncertainty
lockdowns people have tried to open and
it hasn't worked out
tourism officials in bali say the island
has had enough time to prepare for
international visitors
we want to show the outside world that
bali is very much ready
the success of the reopening depends on
whether foreign tourists feel the same
way jessica washington al jazeera bali